if you want to travel by Amtrak from
Houston to San Antonio Texas you only
have one option the sunset limited a
long distance train making 22 stops from
New Orleans to Los Angeles it only runs
three times a week and according to
Amtrak is over an hour and a half late
on average
compare that to the Northeast where 40
Amtrak trains link Philadelphia to New
York every day Amtrak has said for years
that it wants to replicate this model in
fast-growing metropolitan areas like San
Antonio Phoenix and Atlanta but over the
last 50 years the rail network has
remained largely unchanged so why hasn't
Amtrak expanded
but the biggest problem for Amtrak in
areas outside the Northeast is that they
don't control their own fate they're
running along tracks they're owned by
the major Freight railroads of the
country
if Amtrak wants to increase service it
needs to negotiate with freight carriers
but those companies have long resisted
calls to make more room on their tracks
for passenger trains
really this just comes down to an
inevitable tension when the Freights and
passenger railroads have to share a
limited capacity of track the only area
where Amtrak owns most of the tracks is
in the Northeast Corridor for that
reason and because it's much more
heavily a passenger Corridor they're
able to run a lot more trains much more
frequently and that's why you see the
ridership in the Northeast That You
Don't See in other parts of the country
Amtrak has been renting tracks from
freight companies since its Inception
that's because Freight rail used to move
goods and people on its tracks but by
the end of the 1960s they were running
out of money and they were in particular
losing money carrying people so in 1970
Congress bailed out the railroads and
created Amtrak to relieve Freights of
the obligation to provide passenger rail
service
part of the deal was that freight trains
would give Amtrak right of way on its
tracks although the law requires them to
get out of the way and practice they
don't Amtrak blames Freight rail for its
delays saying passenger trains have to
wait for freight trains to pass
according to Amtrak Freight rail caused
passengers nearly 15 000 hours of delays
in 2021 part of the problem is that
Freight Carriers run longer trains some
stretching over two miles if the train
is too long to fit all the way onto that
small siding then you're still going to
be in the way of whatever train is
behind you Amtrak says Freight rail not
only prevents it from operating trains
at higher speeds but also makes it
difficult to add more trains by
demanding excessive Capital Investments
the Freights and their advocates in
Washington can get pretty frustrated
about the passenger rail Advocates not
taking seriously enough the work that
they are doing because so much of the
nation's you know Commodities and goods
are moving around on the rails privately
owned freight companies spend more than
20 billion dollars each year maintaining
and improving their tracks according to
the American Association of railroads a
trade group that includes Amtrak and
freight carriers
the group says Amtrak and Freight rail
share the same goals of providing
efficient and reliable service to both
passengers and Freight customers across
the country this is frame 125. the
freight railroads also say that they do
a better job making way for Amtrak
trains than Amtrak would make it sound
but if the law requires freight trains
to give priority to Amtrak why hasn't
that been enforced there really are two
reasons one is that Amtrak has been
essentially fighting to survive for most
of its history fighting to survive both
because there are people in Congress who
would have loved to have it just go away
also because they just struggled sort of
budget to budget to just keep the lights
on that's partly why Amtrak hasn't
bought more trucks from Freight
railroads because it would be
prohibitively expensive and also the the
freight railroads need these networks so
they would not be you know in the mood
to give up any of this trackage
the second reason Amtrak hasn't really
been successful pushing back against
freight companies is that there hasn't
been a good legal structure for Amtrak
to assert its right rights there was a
railroad regulator called the Interstate
Commerce Commission which was winnowed
down and eventually eliminated the ICC
sometimes did take actions to improve
passenger traffic but it was it was
spotty over the history of of Amtrak but
things started to change in 2008.
Congress passed a law that directed
Amtrak to help develop a set of metrics
and standards to rate the on-time
performance of its trains this would be
a way to measure whether Amtrak trains
were delayed in a way that they're not
supposed to be by freight trains after
years of legal wrangling that led all
the way to the Supreme Court the on-time
metrics took effect in October 2021
which gave Amtrak the ability to begin
building its case against Freight
railroads
in December 2022 Amtrak filed a
complaint against Union Pacific Railroad
its first ever use of the 2008 law in
its complaint Amtrak seized on that
Sunset limited line its most delayed
route in the country this is a sign of
how aggressive Amtrak is becoming about
trying to enforce its rights and being
willing to pick a big fight with the
freight companies a Union Pacific
spokeswoman said the sunset route is a
critical Union Pacific artery and it is
essential that Union Pacific and Amtrak
collaborate to design a schedule that is
reasonable and achievable
the other big change in Amtrak situation
the 2021 infrastructure law this law is
the most significant investment in rail
since we created Amtrak over 50 years
ago the railroad received 22 billion
dollars in direct Aid and will also have
access to 44 billion dollars aimed at
boosting passenger rail service they are
still and will always be reliant on
federal subsidies but their balance
sheet is much stronger they are
replacing cars and locomotives at a rate
that's much higher than anybody has seen
in 2021 Amtrak released its 15-year
Vision which includes improving 25
existing routes and adding 39 new ones
across the U.S imagine trains connecting
Phoenix Tucson and Southern California
Dallas Houston and San Antonio and
Nashville Atlanta and Charlotte Amtrak
says this proposal is a starting point
but the Federal Railroad Administration
will help determine the final plan
they've done a lot of market research
over the past few years about whether
there's demand for passenger rail like
this they also have been doing a really
aggressive job of courting local
officials and Amtrak points to that as
evidence that this will work every study
shows you you get from point A to point
B on rail as faster faster than you can
on automobile you don't take the car you
get in the train but to make sure
customers keep choosing rail over other
Transportation options Amtrak says its
new service can't have hour-long delays
the key to success a new arrangement
with the freight railroads
thank you